pas pour la peine on va revoir votre
[Rires]
maître s'il te plaît tu sais que de la
chance parce que tu as des grosses
fesses et nantes aurait peu de casse et
le coccyx on peut pas dire ça ah si en
principe oui là dedans laisser comme ça
oui merci parce qu'il sait que comment
elle a fait pour ne pas boire le piège
ça veut dire qu'il ya un truc balisé il
ya deux deux petites filles très
sympathique en sélection derrière le
chemin avec des fleurs où vous avez vu
ça donc je donc j'en ai moi aussi mais
on part en fous rires c'est vrai qu'on
voit la chute de kenny c'est
exceptionnel
quelques jours après les faits
vous n'avez rien dit rien du tout je me
suis dit c'est je vais voir les petites
filles qui me tente des flammes on tombe
en panne au bord de la route les gens
que vous attendez que deux fois on y
croit week-end